that's cool so if you were going to
taste some of these chocolates how would
we go about doing it or what's the next
step this experiment there's no there's
a lot of different ways to taste
chocolate the most important thing is
just to sort of take your time and and
really pay attention to what is is going
out of here in your mouth okay and every
time I put a piece of chocolate in my
not they really try to just just pay
attention okay that's that's really the
most important thing and there's you can
sort of go either way you can you can go
from dark to light or you can go from
light to dark I attended prefer those
dark to light so why don't we start with
the 82% extrañar okay you put this
particular waste in your mouth how did I
just die you through the mouth chew it
up for a little bit and then I just sort
of let the flavors my tongue and just
try them very good turn the trip through
my mouth but you know just sort of just
fine that's where the world works with
you everyone have sort a different
technique that maximizes their and their
ability today okay that's the flavor but
I want to be see I can pretend to be a
wines done no no I'm working on my
repertoire for being a chocolates not
sweat all right so I'm missing the
vocabulary so how would you describe
this well I like to look at eating
chocolate as a as a very temporal thing
and I'll flavor it really is whatever
you wine or cheese or chocolate so in
the beginning of this flavor experience
for me I noticed that right on the onset
there's there's a lot of sort of free
sort of a dark-brown foods on the screen
there's a little bit of a tobacco note
in there sort of a sweet note and it
really evolves into sort of a slight
astringency where a little bit of white
a new note now this is definitely a
chocolate for it's very complex some of
our best means and it really has a
lingering finish oftentimes tasting a
piece of chocolate you might want to
even leave you know two or three minutes
we won't we won't do that today
that's right really take your take take
your time I finish important thing yeah
the finish can really change and more
even long after you sort of have it out
of your mouth like if it's a scotch
Genaro now the man on the camera knows
this Glenlivet I may have to punish them
for introducing me to scotch but it's
good in moderation again still let's
let's if you don't mind because I I've
had vast quantities in 70% example of it
yeah let's try something on on this
scale I've never had 75 I've actually
been here is that hair some hero
this is also unique it's a very
different blend than any of our bars
so now did you travel to each of these
countries yourself in the process of
sourcing these beans we have yes
Trinidad Grenada the Dominican Republic
in coastal Venezuela yeah yeah over what
period of time with the exception of
Grenada but a co-worker like that well
this is great
now how would you contrast that to the
82 well I think there are similarities
it has but the Antilles bar I really
pick out the more of a a ripe fruit
flavor it's not as not as much more
dried fruit this is one it has some
citrus notes yeah it's gonna say if I
were going to contrast it to wine it
seems like that would have more tenants
or is this we have not but say and part
of that is the hardest part of that is
the sugar level but but the majority of
that difference really lies
and variation between the beans and
beans can be very very different
Sookie if you have for example coffee
and so I also like coffee we're talking
about this before about sourcing coffee
and I've been to two coffee plants and
factories so Costa Rica in other places
so depending on how long you roast
something for one can really change the
flow of it so you have these beans that
have their own characteristics for each
country and each I suppose a lot of
foods before the time how important is
the duration of roasting are all the
beans roasted for roughly the same
amount of time now everything has its
own unique robot so being from Ghana for
instance is going to have a different
roast time than a bean from Madagascar
and then
from Java to Venezuela Costa Rica and so
each one is very
we looked at also do you want to what
would be your next pick of this bunch
well why don't we not have to ask you
yeah of these you have to choose your
personal favorite of course put you on
the spot which which one would it be in
the understanding that each has its own
place sure it's just like a jury lots of
wine depends on if it's after dinner
dessert wine or whatever but what would
be your in general your indulgence of
chose well I think I probably I probably
pick the Antilles I really love the idea
this is good that's why first time trial
and I really of it that just I really
love that sugar level then when you say
show me five percent okay so if it's
seventy five percent dry happen right
it's a twenty five percent by volume is
roughly sugar by weight by weight yeah
okay Gunnar and you you mentioned the
let's go with it so maybe I do our
chocolate oh so what what is less than
used for maybe you can explain what what
the multiplier actually yeah well an
emulsifier and for our purposes is
really there's a lot of different
there's a lot of different ingredients
that go into chocolate well especially
when you're looking at well in short
mm-hmm
chocolate
as fat right there's also sugar
and so to really allow those to combine
well and it requires an extensive
brightening process and also the process
codes caution budget yeah and and so
adding soy lecithin really enables the
child so much smoother it allows it to
have a better mouthfeel right exciting
so it's like if you imagine oil and
water yeah getting those mixed properly
that the process of emulsification
conscious of doing yeah very cool you
want to try one of these yeah let's try
to let's try the 62mm over to the no and
what's a semi-sweet me semi-sweet is
sort of a it's a very broadly used term
as is bittersweet yeah so what would
those two if somebody goes in the store
and they say okay well I know what dark
means I know I don't chocolate means
inter sweet semi-sweet no idea yeah well
I think I'm gonna get this yeah please
semi-sweet is is really semi-sweet and
bittersweet are very royal in this terms
and there are some legal definitions but
they don't really apply in a lot of ways
to some of the some of the chocolate
that we're looking at
today in reality it's really one of the
reasons why people are starting to use
these percentages of cocoa is because it
really helps people understand exactly
how I darker chocolate family and and so
semi-sweet can really run the range from
anywhere from 40% cocoa content and all
the way to to maybe 60 to okay
by the order or more and then a
bittersweet can also range from 35 to 40
percent all the way to 85 percent while
really there's sort of antiquated terms
so now sorry less that has its own
health benefits also just as an
additional excuse for me to continue to
eat chocolate